[Music]
on this Saturday night searching for
survivors the death toll mounts in Maui
as Crews comb through the wreckage where
wildfires hit without warnings
looks like the whole places blew up plus
Canadians caught in the chaos
deadly Journey more migrants drown in
Europe as the number of attempted
Crossings climbs
artificial intelligence and tourism been
a tool that has come in handy for
planning itineraries how AI is planning
your next holiday
global national with faronasso reporting
tonight Jeff Semple
a moment of sheer Terror as this family
that flees the fires that wiped out much
of the historic Hawaiian town of Lahaina
this week they're now among the
thousands in Maui left homeless after
the deadliest natural disaster in
Hawaii's history
good evening and thank you for joining
us the death toll from that Inferno now
stands at 80 and around a thousand
people are still missing the fire is now
mostly contained and some survivors are
returning to find their community in
Ruins arnithu garcha is in Maui and has
been speaking with evacuees including a
Canadian School principal so nithu
what's the latest on the situation there
Jeff some people were allowed to return
to Lahaina yesterday before the road was
closed off to others who remain in the
dark about whether their loved ones are
alive people across the island are
anxious and banding together to support
each other however they can
we were just helping people that came to
our school Canadian principal Ryan
Kirkham who's lived on Maui for years
says when the wildfires broke out
Tuesday night his school known as Maui
prep was spared but quickly became an
evacuation and distribution center I'm
one of the first buses that came I
carried a little old 82 year old woman
off the bus just she she was just black
head to toe and and but she had been in
the ocean for three hours
and somebody picked her up put her on a
bus
Kirkham drove through the devastated
community of Lahaina for the first time
on Friday since The Inferno tore through
the town it was heartbreaking just
everything flattened down to the ground
it's completely unrecognizable there's
nothing it is we were driving we were
like
I have no idea where we are right now
like Kona Deneen also made it into the
restricted area for the first time
Friday so much destruction it's insane
over there it's like a war zone it's
things just it looks like the whole
place just blew up
deneen's home and family were spared he
spent his days picking up and dropping
off donations where they're most needed
as a Hawaiian also mourning the loss of
sacred lands he's hoping the historic
banyan tree with branches extending over
18 meters Will Survive it's really hard
to fight this
as people wait in long lines to get into
Lahaina through the uncertainty of
what's next Kirkham says many are
defiant and determined to Rise From the
Ashes West Maui and Lahaina just has a
weird way of of pulling together and and
just kind of shaking their fists at the
circumstances and and
and saying you know what you might knock
us down but we're just going to come
back stronger
The Compassion here is on display
wherever we go but we have also heard
some growing frustrations local police
here have reported some of those who've
been allowed back into Lahaina have been
breaking the rules and going into
restricted locations there have also
been many reports of looting Jeff
in Maui thanks nithu
Lahaina has a rich history it was once
Hawaii's capital and offered a wide
array of cultural and historical sites
like the Banyan tree that nithu
mentioned and while it's still standing
many other sites were wiped out by the
wildfires they include the Old Lahaina
Courthouse which opened back in 1860 and
housed a Heritage Museum the 200 year
old wyola church is now reduced to
rubble and the Baldwin House built in
1834 and believed to be the oldest home
on Maui was also destroyed
residents say that Wildfire hit without
warning and some are now demanding to
know why their large Seaside Community
was caught off guard as Reggie zucchini
explains experts say this fire offers
lessons for the future
so many there are no words to describe
the loss of this paradise I suppose my
freaking thing I've ever been through
but there are questions about why so
many things went wrong Hawaii is
extremely vulnerable to Wildfire
um and this has just been getting worse
uh over the last few decades local
officials are believed to have
underestimated the threat posed by fire
even as reports highlighted how
unprepared the state was for a wildfire
disaster that's only been exacerbated by
a changing climate that includes severe
drought after a big event like this a
devastating event like this there's
always a in-depth study and Analysis of
not only the fire Behavior and the
weather and the conditions that caused
it but what actions did Emergency
Management take there was a Red Flag
Warning that weather could impact fire
conditions but emergency officials say
warning sirens were not activated and
cellular outages may have prevented
emergency alerts from reaching everyone
the fires came up so quickly and they
spread so fast I think this was an
impossible situation it was a situation
worsened by the fact Maui and most of
Hawaii is covered by vast grasslands
that can reach a meter high our Island
archipelago has been invaded by fire
prone grasses from all over the world so
when our native Forest Burns what comes
back is more of these grasses
there are calls to look forward by
learning from mistakes of the past there
needs to be a lot more long-term
planning and and more resources put
towards fire prevention a great tactic
for that is using livestock to actually
graze those grasses if we accept as a
society that these events will happen
again how can we best protect ourselves
and the things we care about from those
events experts say prevention and not
blame should be a primary focus and
while recovery is only just beginning
the rebuild needs to be far more
adaptive to a fast changing environment
Global News Washington
turning to the migrant crisis in Europe
now at least six Asylum Seekers have
been killed after their boat sank in the
English Channel it's the latest in a
string of similar tragedies more than
one thousand migrants have tried to make
the journey to the UK by boat in just
the last two days history isri reports
those who survive the journey face tough
new immigration measures
foreign
a boat packed with migrants sank in one
of the busiest and most dangerous
shipping lanes in the world Rescuers
found them off the coast of France
stranded at Sea and screaming for help
the boat was quite simply overloaded
says this man they could no longer move
they saved around 50 people but could
not reach everyone the migrants who died
were from Afghanistan a country that's
been under Taliban control for almost
two years I was driving people now is
more political
day earlier a rescue ship found a
stranded Wooden Boat near Malta the
number of migrants arriving on Europe's
Shores is increasing and so are the
casualties
this summer at least 350 Pakistani
Nationals died in a disaster off the
coast of Greece what we see in the
Mediterranean Sea at the moment are we
are counting almost 2 000 persons that
have drunk already this year which is
the highest death toll since 2017
European countries are cracking down the
British government temporarily housed
Asylum Seekers on a barge despite
warnings it's a potential death trap on
Friday they were moved after the
bacteria that causes Legionnaires
disease was found in the water supply
it's not solving any of the systemic
issues or failings within our Asylum
system what we're doing here is cropping
up a formative cruelty more than a
hundred thousand migrants have crossed
the English Channel in small vessels
since 2018. when they arrive they often
face a massive backlog and few options
it basically it comes down to there's no
legal Pathways and you're very slow at
processing and people need to leave
A desperate Journey that doesn't end on
the shore
a esri Global News Ottawa
turning to Ukraine now Russia says its
air defenses shut down at least three
Ukrainian missiles fired at a bridge
connecting Russia to occupied Crimea
video on social media shows plumes of
white smoke over the Kirch Bridge
Russia's defense Ministry claims that
smoke was intentionally created to
thwart further strikes Russia annexed
Crimea back in 2014.
with no end in sight to the war in
Ukraine tensions are rising in
neighboring Poland particularly along
its border with Belarus the Polish
government claims Belarusian military
helicopters entered its airspace at the
beginning of the month in response
Poland's government ordered 10 000
troops to the border to bolster defenses
while on the other side mercenaries from
Russia's Wagner group are reportedly
training belarussian forces those
military Maneuvers are making NATO
Nations nervous tonight Crystal
commencing looks at the work underway to
keep Poland safe
an important anniversary is approaching
this Tuesday polish soldiers will be
marching to commemorate their 1920
victory over the Soviets Red Army but
with current day hostilities as many as
10 000 troops are being handed new
orders
we have to be ready for any scenario
explained the Polish defense minister
saying this is why we decided to move
the Army closer to the border to scare
away the aggressor Russia's battle heart
and Wagner group has been training
belarussian soldiers reportedly at the
request of President Alexander
lukashenka troops have reportedly come
within five kilometers of Polish
territory since the training started
last month and on August 1st Poland
accused Belarus of illegally entering
its airspace
Russia's defense minister says the
militarization of Poland poses a risk to
Russia several NATO countries along the
defensive group's Eastern flank stepped
up border patrols and repositioned
weapons following Russia's full invasion
of Ukraine
the Polish prime minister says Russia
and Belarus are sowing chaos and unrest
with their veiled threats and recent
actions including cyber attacks not just
against Poland but Lithuania and Latvia
we need to be prepared for all kinds of
possible provocations also in the future
for Poland that means more manpower to
physically guard the Border in an effort
to keep the peace because an attack on a
NATO Nation would draw in all member
countries including Canada into the
conflict
Crystal gemancing Global News London
upgrading your travel experience coming
up how artificial intelligence could
help your next holiday
welcome back artificial intelligence
just might join you on your next
vacation tourism Jasper in Alberta's
Rocky Mountains is now using AI in hopes
of making the destination more popular
and they're not alone as Heather York's
West explains applications like chat GPT
and Oliver AI are taking the industry by
storm
watch now as Oliver takes the input on
traveling Italy as a vegan and produces
an 800 word blog post in real time it's
not quite an artificial travel agent but
it is an AI application real life travel
agent Tana sterland finds helpful it's
been a tool that has come in handy for
planning itineraries for being able to
answer questions rather quickly for
clients and suppliers dearland uses chat
GPT to support clients too just one of
the ways this new technology is changing
how people travel with seemingly
Limitless possibilities teams at tourism
destinations are taking note travel is
very complicated there are many
different externalities to why and how
people travel Jasper is one of the most
beautiful getaway spots in Alberta with
demand high it's why tourism Jasper has
teamed up with the Alberta machine
intelligence Institute to get artificial
intelligence working for them it could
be from optimizing travel for safety and
efficiency it could be how do we use AI
to find even more experiences for people
in the park how can we optimize the
opportunity for seasonal hiring and tour
operator efficiency unlike traditional
database decision making software which
looks at Trends over time AI focuses on
the future allowing companies to make
plans based on what the technology says
will happen next hypothetically we'll be
able to provide insights on everything
from dispersion as to how Vehicles
travel within the park to human Wildlife
conflict to climate change and
sustainability around glaciation and
that type of thing when it comes to the
tourism sector AI appears to be here to
stay a recent American study found a
third of U.S Travelers are now using
chat GPT to plan their trips with travel
companies like Expedia getting in on the
action too
sending Travelers off on New Adventures
on the wings of A.I Heather urich's West
Global News Calgary
still ahead a new lease on life how a
Canadian company is driving forward with
old electric car batteries
when a gas-powered vehicle gets old it
often ends up in a wrecking yard but
that outcome can be more complicated
when the car is electric Krista Hesse
explains
[Music]
welcome to the urban mine
there's no hole in the ground or
tailings
these minerals are coming from a new
source
electric car batteries
it's very cool kind of looks like dirt
but kind of looks like dirt guarantee
it's not dirt
that dark shiny material is called Black
Mass it's a concoction of minerals made
from old or defective batteries that
have been shredded and broken down
black mass is the bread and butter of
life cycle a Canadian battery recycler
that wants to make sure the Precious
Minerals and batteries don't go to waste
so how many batteries get recycled at
this facility it's 5 000 tons per year
it's a lot of batteries it's a lot of
batteries Daniel Demers is the plant
manager here at life Cycle's facility in
Kingston Ontario he gave us a close-up
look at how the recycling process works
this is a skid of modules in an EV car
the entire bottom of the car would be
full of these
we take off the bits and pieces that
that we don't want to shred
and then we lift it up onto the conveyor
and send it on its merry way up into the
center
[Music]
the lithium ion battery recycling
industry which barely existed a few
years ago is now booming there really
hasn't been a change of this scale since
the last time we moved from the horse
and buggy to the original combustion
engine which you know was a process that
took over 100 years we're trying to get
there in just a couple decades lithium
Cobalt nickel graphite and manganese are
crucial for these new batteries but you
can't open a mine overnight
mines take a long time to build in most
countries so we've got this supply and
demand crunch that's being forecast
that's where recycling comes in starting
in 2030 the first wave of electric
vehicle batteries are expected to reach
their end of life
part of the solution to this supply
problem lies in what happens to those EV
batteries when they run out of juice
lithium is the most valuable component
now those batteries
before starting life cycle AJ kochar
worked in battery manufacturing as an
engineer
he watched as lithium ion became the
most popular battery chemistry and then
started looking into whether any
recyclers were recovering lithium and to
our dismay we found that you actually
can't recover lithium through these
traditional approaches which tend to
burn off materials they don't want so
that was really an aha moment for us
right now life cycles black mass is sold
to outside vendors but later this year
they will open a new plant in Upstate
New York it's there that they'll use a
new chemical process to recover the
various minerals from the Black Mass
including lithium think of it as Urban
Mining and how much are you able to
reuse from those batteries that you're
recycling so we're getting up to 95
recoverable material from those
batteries with a new stream of battery
grade materials coming from recyclers it
could reduce the need for Mining and all
the impacts that come along with it this
solves a problem gets it out of the
landfill gets it back into industry gets
it back into your next device Krista
Hesse Global News affectionately
referred to as Joey Batts the Superstar
Slugger returned to the roster by
signing a one-day contract on Friday
allowing him to officially retire as a
blue jay I spoke with Bautista about his
most memorable moments including that
Unforgettable bat flip mark his
induction into the Jay's level of
Excellence Toronto unveiled this bat
flip mural downtown fans at the game
even received bat flip bobble heads what
do you think about the way that moment
eight years later has become almost
immortalized in Canadian sports I think
it's awesome you know there's a few
moments out there for Canadians famous
to to remember obviously Joe Carter some
run Kawhi Leonard shot and and hopefully
a bad flip so I know it means a lot but
uh it means a lot to me as well so uh
just happy that I was able to create
some great memories for fans it helped
it was a pretty sweet flip at the time I
won't ask about your bat flip technique
I've even got an extra microphone in
case you want to demonstrate
is it all on the wrist or how does how
does it work so much technique so I
don't really remember how I did it or
why but I just kind of gave it like a
little toss to the to the right you know
that's it I mean we got insurance all
that so you could give it all right I'll
give it a flip there it is
that a boy we're all done and finally I
guess to be back in the City I mean I
always talked a lot about your memories
with the team but your memories in in
the country in the city what's it like
to to be back here it's great to be back
it feels like I've never left so I'm
glad to be back and I'm sure I'll be
back more often it's just we're coming
back to Canada it feels like such a
welcome in place
um such great diversity and a lot of
culture here so I enjoy my time here all
the time and that is global national for
this Saturday night I'm Jeff Semple from
Baseball Stars to shooting stars you
might want to stay up late this evening
to catch a glimpse of the preceded
meteor shower which Peaks tonight thanks
for watching have a great night